waffen wochen wochen das ist das einzige
was zu den screens derzeit wirklich
inständig bittet darum und deswegen
müssen wir jetzt waffen liefern und man
muss mal klar definieren was ist denn
das ziel dieser auseinandersetzt unserer
sicht beim entstehen hört mal raus es
ging nur darum jetzt schnell wie
mögliche zufrieden zu sitze schaffen
natürlich wollen wir alle so schnell wie
möglich erreichen dass sie nicht will
ich will in diesem ziel dass putin nicht
gewinnt publizistik krieg nicht gewinnen
und deshalb müssen wir alles tun um der
ukraine jetzt unter die arme zu greifen
die tschechen liefern jetzt panzer wir
haben aus der slowakei heraus
flugabwehrraketen weil wir europäer eben
nicht bereits in einem flugzeug zu bauen
machen dass die ukraine selbst aber
dafür brauchen sie waffen und deswegen
gibt es für mich überhaupt keine frage
jetzt in großem umfang waffen liefern
auch ein mäßiges grenze für unsere pr in
bis zu eigenen verteidigungsfähigkeiten
müssen wir jetzt durch ganz oben
angreifen und das hauptargument dabei
ist dieser krieg ist eben nicht ein
russisch ukrainische krieg diese kritik
russlands gegen uns alle ganz ganz runde
also militärischer sieg ist aus ihrer
sicht ganz klar dass hier ganz kurz ja
oder nein was ist das ziel der füchse
militärischer sieg gegen putin gegen die
russischen truppen
der eu außenkommissarin der mit frau von
der leyen in käfer hat das zum ersten
mal offen ausgesprochen hat nämlich
gesagt dieser krieg wird auf dem
schlachtfeld entschieden
und das heißt wir müssen alles tun damit
die ukraine in gewinnt so und davor
scheut die bundesregierung noch zurück
das so klar auszusprechen hersteller
militärischer sieg ist aus ihrer sicht
nicht das ziel oder kann nicht das ziel
sein erste ziel muss sein dass der krieg
aufhört waffenruhe humanitäre hilfen und
natürlich kein diktat frieden aber man
muss auch bedenken wir reden über die
zweitgrößte atommacht der welt und das
sagt sich sehr leicht was hier
formuliert wird ich glaube dass das ganz
schwierig ist dann hat ein elendes blut
opfer zur folge wenn wir über wochen
lang stellungskrieg reden das kann nicht
die richtige antwort sein und ich
bezweifle auch dass militärische logik
alleine geht hallo herr oberbeck wie
tragen sie sich mit der frage nach
waffenlieferungen wir hören ein weber
der sagt waffen waffen waffen gehören
herren höchster sagt zitiert herren
borel der sagt das wird auf dem
schlachtfeld entschieden wir hören herrn
stegner der sich schwer damit tut und
nach einer bach ruhe ruft wie verhält
sich die katholische kirche in dieser
schwierigen frage waffen waffen waffen
damit wir putin besiegen
das ist eine auseinandersetzung kommt
dem ist das autokratische system auf der
anderen seite erwartet nicht starten
demokratischer systeme ich kann auch nur
sagen wir müssen für die gerade recht
hat die demokratische hauptpunkt sein
und das alles tun innerhalb der kirche
ist das relativ bestritten und fährt und
auch untereinander noch sehr klar und es
gibt diejenigen sagen muss dass ein
frieden geben wir verhandeln kann das
ist derjenigen die sorgen und eindeutig
auf die seite der ukraine geschlagen
dann die vielen die sich unentschieden
darf denn für mich ist ziemlich klar
dass das ganze ein ethischer fertig ist
und auch bleibt und angesichts der
vielen vielen vielen formen von
verhandlungen dieser stattgefunden haben
sich ganz ohne lügen die durchsichtige
angestellt haben habe ich dem ganzen
nicht mehr wenn ich ehrlich bin aber
auch von mir selber als militärbischof
trete auch in meinem gewissen wirklich
gefragt dieser frage wer kann man das
verantworten möglicherweise einen
wirklichen ätherischen existieren tricks
und das mit vielen opfern leider frage
ich mich gleich was passiert ihm das
nicht und gibt es genauso viele
aufführungen auf der anderen seite und
von daher gesehen
die entscheidung trifft ist also
zwischen zwei schlechten optionen aber
dann müssten diejenigen treffen die auf
dauer für eine schweiz will ich alle
menschen das kostet viel